welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
I'm the pastor at the table where our
mission is to shift a generation from
reactionary to visionary through the
person and work of Jesus so last week I
talked about what the Bible calls the
the flesh versus the Spirit or as more
modern Christian writers call it the
false self versus the true self now
here's the thing the challenge with
those terms is that unless you have an
immediate intuitive experience of what
I'm talking about
it can sound very abstract sort of like
a spiritual mumbo-jumbo maybe you're
thinking look buddy I live in the real
world with real problems and I don't got
time to discover my true self whatever
the heck that means
right I need facts I need science okay
fair enough with that in mind today I
want to talk about the connection I see
between the language of the false and
true self and something called the
default mode network or the D in in for
short
so the dmn is a collection of brain
areas related to processing emotions
recalling memories and thinking about
what is to come in other words it's that
part of the brain that gets louder when
we get quieter it's that self
referential stream of thought going
through your mind pretty much all the
time when you aren't completely absorbed
in something it's that mind wandering
daydreaming part of us now
daydreaming that doesn't sound too bad
when there's truth in that the DM in at
its best it can be a source of insight
creativity however most of the time it's
not most of the time it's a useless
stream of obsessing about past events
worrying endlessly about future events
or telling incredibly fear-based
negative stories about my life world and
the people around me how could you look
at me like that
I knew she hated me or when something
negative happens and your mind begins to
play out this absolutely terrible worst
case scenario of cascading events that
is about to bring about you or doom it's
the reason that is one comedian put it
everything is amazing and nobody's happy
I mean think about it we all should be
skipping through our days like alright I
have more food in my pantry then my
great-grandfather saw in a year
I have no fear that wild beasts will
kill me
my life is grand but nope that pesky DNN
gets rolling and makes us quite
miserable interesting footnote one of
you of depression is that it's a brain
that is stuck in the default mode
network some people have an overactive
DM in and oh my goodness that will make
you miserable okay so say Brett what
does this have to do with the whole
false self true self thing well what I
want to suggest is that the Christian
concept of the false self corresponds
very closely if not entirely to what
neuroscientists would call your default
mode Network and here's another big idea
the quieter you are d + n / false self
gets the more in touch you become with
your true self now what is the true self
well it's that part of us that has
always been through the Holy Spirit
deeply and profoundly connected to God
it's that part of us that when the
static white noise of the D in n drops
away we're like peace what joy the world
is shining and God is smiling through
all things but unfortunately most of our
days are spent with a very noisy demon
okay so what's a person to do well this
is where the Christian contemplative
tradition comes in by contemplative I
don't mean Christians thinking very deep
in lofty things I mean that stream of
Christianity that is interested in
giving people practices that actually
help us overcome the dmn tap into our
true selves and experience a deeper
union with God so who would these
Christian contemplatively be it would be
folks like the Desert Fathers desert
mothers or in more modern times
Christians like the Thomas Merton Thomas
Keating send people or goal and what
would they tell you to do well they'll
tell you to practice see things like
prayer fasting scripture reading
journaling confession community therapy
silence and so on are all ways that we
learn to notice the false self and begin
to move away from it and eventually
silence it now the implication of this
is that spiritual practices actually
matter not just so that you can go to
heaven or get on God's good side it
matters for your life it matters for
your mental and emotional health it
matters for your family matters for your
church in your community
it matters okay
well that's all for today if you enjoyed
this video please like and share it and
subscribe to future episodes grace and
peace